no more 10 slides is too big for a.m  party is over yeah  my teammates used to get mad as hell at  me like i used to go in big and tall and  buy everything up wait wait you really  went into big and tired being 4x  t-shirts  45  at the practice i would beat them there  you know what i mean and i would buy  everything and they'd come in here and  get mad at me because i would buy up all  the big clothes did you just like the  look like did you want to look like  you've been kind of swallowed by by your  clothes it was in style  and then i was you know i had to  probably i had the little man complex  because i always wanted the big old  rolls royce and the biggest car and you  know what i mean i was  165 then so yeah you know i wanted the  biggest clothes i didn't want to look  small smaller than everybody else so  i don't know and it was a style back  then i don't know who i  don't know it was just the guys from my  neighborhood used to dress like that so